as podcast has bad words hmm
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast we discuss what it
means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Milburn I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists welcome to episode 125
Ryan today we're gonna talk about
quality
I like quality our our friendship is I
feel like high-quality quality is my
favorite quantity amen Devon I and I
think this is the perfect time for
during this little preamble here before
we dive into our listeners questions to
talk about some screw-ups occasionally
we screw some stuff up it's funny I
screwed something up this this weekend
and it drove me insane I know I just
wanted to tell you it was gonna be okay
yeah well I just wanted to tell you it's
not a big deal but like I
I just know you and like that doesn't
help yeah that just makes you say it's
something it's something it doesn't help
but it's in billing it's like you I
could say dude it's not a big deal and
you're gonna say hey Ryan I appreciate
that right but it is a big deal yeah I
mean you have to come over and help me
hide the bodies right exactly exactly
what chipper no and that's the thing
like when you put it in perspective it's
like it really isn't that big of a deal
but I've worked so hard on this essay
about advertisements over the last three
months let me make sure my phone's in
airplane mode so I can throw it out the
window no it doesn't fly watch I worked
so hard this essay it's called can we
have a conversation about advertisements
can we have an honest conversation
months you've been spending months on it
yeah it's a lie I our first book that we
wrote minimal of meaningful life took
about the same amount of time as this
damn essay and it got to this point
where it's about 10,000 words and I read
a few books and a bunch of different
articles and essays and history about
advertising and tried to incorporate in
there and also sort of distill it down
to its essence try to make it about
3,000 words I think it ended up just
over 4,000 words at the end of the day
and and man it was it was this thing
that
it was ready it was 98% there all it
need was this fine-tooth editing that we
have podcast Shawn for because he is our
podcast editor but he's also the best
writing editor that I've ever met a man
and so he does such a great job taking a
weed whacker and a red pen and other
instruments of torture to him damage
yeah I think he I think he went to like
Costco and just bought a bunch of em
dashes he's got he's got em dashes on
sale
let's see what three in this sentence we
love you we love you it is you will poke
someone's aisle with those in - your
shop put him away but no he is a great
editor he is fond of em - as we've had
several long conversations about the use
of em dashes I give him two per si now
but man it was so close and then I
accidentally hit the publish button and
didn't know I hit it I thought it hit
save draft and and then it just
published that night as opposed to the
wins day was supposed to go out and oh
it's weird because ever since you sent
that out I noticed we've had zero people
visiting the website since traffic has
decreased by a hundred percent and that
and not to mention the mob of people
holding signs on that I cannot run I
couldn't I couldn't believe it I just
couldn't believe you know a clash you
got from that thing I couldn't believe
we got from it is how few typos there
actually were in it but there were there
about a dozen typos in it which I I
would expect that there'd be far more
from from you know this ten thousand
word thing that was cut down so much and
there was also at least one in accuracy
can paragraph I had to move completely
it wasn't ready to go out to the world
yet it was a really solid first draft
but it wasn't ready to go out to the
world and so by the time this episode
comes out it'll already be out there you
can check it out the minimalists comm
slash ads but as a retraction sort of
not even a retraction but a owning up to
my own mistake I wrote this really short
essay
oops and basically it just said hey over
the past few years I've spent a great
deal of time contemplating the overreach
of the advertising industry and then
this is last week after countless hours
of research and rumination I finally
finished writing an essay that
articulated my thoughts on advertising
all I needed was some editing but then I
accidentally hit the button and then I'd
go into apologizing and talk about how
the error was especially frustrating
because of the time that I spent on is
it's like this crucial tremendously
important topic to me and I just wanted
to get it right out there the first time
and not have this thing that was sort of
I had a few bruises on it right yeah but
here's the thing like I I also didn't
expect it to be perfect I know I wanted
it to be like I've got this
perfectionist mentality and actually
this whole thing made me spawn this
other essay that's out there it'll
actually be it'll be published by the
time that this this podcast is out it's
called how to be anxious it's just a
perfect list of everything you can do if
you don't have enough anxiety in your
life these are things you can think
about here's what you can do to be
anxious yeah
which actually would be a great book
title I just don't have I don't have the
time to write an entire book on how to
be anxious so instead you get a blog
post out there the minimalists calm
slash anxious I think it will be we'll
put a link to those in the show notes as
well the whole point about this is today
we're talking about quality but we also
have to mess things up along the way I I
thought about this this quote I pulled
up I'm a big fan of Charles Eames you
probably see some of his furniture like
Herman Miller store and in places like
that the Eames chair that I have in fact
a really high quality sort of iconic
chair that will probably be with me for
the rest of my life and yes beautiful
stuff unless I decide to let go of it
right sure I'm I'm always open to
letting go of it I don't have an
attachment to it but it is a piece of
art he said this about quality Ryan and
really stood out to me and I think this
will be the the sort of theme of this
episode eventually everything connects
people ideas objects the quality of the
connections is the key to quality
so so I think the the when we're talking
about quality and quite often when we're
talking about minimalism the irony of
this is we're often talking about
material possessions or the lack thereof
or the material possessions that add
value to our lives and thus we want to
have quality things in our life you and
I don't want to eschew everything and
live you know in a concrete room with no
bed or whatever but with the things we
bring into our life we want to be
quality and and part of that quality has
to do as Charles Eames talks about here
is the those things help well I would
say augment our life but really it
connects up it connects us quite often
if you have a couch you want to be able
to share that couch with your partner or
your friends who come over you're
sharing that because it it augment it
augments the connection in a way between
the people the ideas and and the objects
and so today we're gonna talk a lot
about about the quality of things we
bring into our lives also the quality of
time the quality of experiences that we
have so I think we should we should
probably go ahead and Diane yeah
definitely meant one thing I do want to
say before we dive into these voicemails
here man is I think you accidentally
publishing that essay was a great lesson
for our listeners for a couple reasons a
it's not the ember world we did not have
zero people visit the website the next
day right Sean got very few emails about
about anything needing editing it was a
it was a very very benign response I
mean for all intents and purposes it was
a benign response I agree on top of that
dude we have done such an outstanding
job and I you know me dude I don't I'd
hardly likes it here and Pat us on the
back right but we do such an outstanding
job of putting our best foot forward to
making sure that the quality we put out
in these podcasts and our essays with
the document whatever it is that we do
that when something like this happens
it's a very easy thing to overlook yeah
in fact I I would I would argue and say
that some people who got that essay and
then when it was redacted because it
wasn't edited might have gotten even
more excited to think like oh this is
gonna be even better yeah it was in my
inbox
yeah because they know they expect the
quality and we've been consist
than with that I agree and so like I put
out a little note I put the note out on
on Facebook that was basically saying
hey oops I screwed this up and I got so
many comments on Facebook and Instagram
that people are like oh so you are human
and and you know I didn't even notice I
read it this morning wasn't mine cause
it went out to hundreds of thousands of
email inboxes all right beat our hole if
you're on our newsletter list or just
email list on the website you get any
new essays that we publish for free
obviously they just show up in your
inbox and so it went there's no way for
me to like go out there take it back on
the people's inboxes it was the air and
I had a bunch of people saying I enjoyed
I enjoyed it typos and all right and and
I didn't most people I didn't even
notice the typos right and because there
was you know maybe a dozen in there an
article that was a instead of an or what
else so how we're leaving was that for
you man because I guarantee you the
person who was most upset was you
oh yeah so after after you know you kind
of realized our audience aren't just a
bunch of grammar nazis actually dude if
someone would have like responded back
and been like all right Kenneth your
quality is really lacking in this essay
I'm never gonna read anything again go
[ __ ] yourself that's that's what I think
well it's funny cuz you you properly
good point a second ago we do work hard
to make sure our quality is it's
top-notch not perfect but it's the best
that can be given the resources we have
in fact I think this is the third time
we've tried to record this episode about
qualities at the third time yeah could
we try to do two in one day and like you
left and you came back and we were just
kind of like yeah yes so this is like
this is like version 2.5 but that's the
point I was having coffee with our
friend Lewis house this morning
and he was like he's like what are you
doing to them like I gotta leave here
soon we gotta go record this podcast
that we messed up last week he's like
what do you mean I'm like man for every
podcast we put out we'd probably record
to at least recently recently I don't
dude I did yeah and that's not always
the case when it started it was like one
out of every four or yeah but and then
we got better and better and as the
quality improved you don't have to I
quite often I see these sometimes these
conversations you want to have is
drats and if we and sometimes the first
draft is good enough and it's
outstanding in fact sometimes there's a
certain magic to that first draft you
can't recapture if you try to come back
and affect the conversation again so
last time we recorded this we we did in
an afternoon because we we had this we
did that Frank Lloyd Wright house who
went out speaking of quality I'm amazing
Toria we went to go out look at this
Frank Lloyd Wright house
Olive Hill right yeah al Hill hollyhock
yeah the hollyhock house we'll put a
link to that in the show notes Oh any
one's in LA you have to set up a docent
tour weeks in advance like you at the
email was so worth it though it was
definitely worth it I mean the quality
it was was amazing but we went and did
that and then we were kind of tired
after doing that we came back and it
would have been a good enough podcast to
publish probably but the there was a
special irony to calling a podcast
quality and then not having it be the
absolute quality that we liked yeah the
party was just the feeling - well yeah -
I it's all my fault no I'm you know I'm
happy to talk about what's been going on
with me recently I found out I was
basically pre-diabetic type-2 so I got
that confirmed last Friday so today's
Tuesday literally like three or four
days ago doc Greene called me and he's
like Eddie you're not you're not
diabetic yet which is the word was there
which is great news yeah he's like but
you do have to change you have to do
some major lifestyle changes well in the
process of me doing these changes I have
been really doing amazing on my diet
like I've lost I think I was like 2 to
17 banging into this here I'm like 201
200 pounds now you can see your face it
looks good man thanks man just over the
last few weeks because because I'm
taking it so seriously like I have I can
literally count on one hand how many
drinks I've had this year I can I I can
tell you how many time how many french
fries I've had you're going to keep
counting right right right exactly
exactly no no but what I'm saying is is
that is that I have really gone out of
my way to change my diet but what I
didn't realize is how how sugar masks so
much of the symptoms that
like I didn't do you see what I'm saying
yeah so it's like I have become more
irritable I have become more brain foggy
and I've been sticking to that
intermittent fasting schedule but it's
really been screwing with me because I
haven't been eating I've literally been
eating zero sugar I mean right some
carbs very low carb yeah very low carbs
very low sugar so like these last two
weeks I've been trying to like wrap my
head around like what the hell is going
on like why do I feel so off and my
body's translation finally hit me I'm
like dude you have you've taken sugar
out of your body and I'm like I'm going
through this weird withdrawal thing yeah
something man
jonesing for the car but you know what
dude like I'd never like I had to force
myself to eat this morning just so I
would have some food in my stomach and
be able to to be alert and have a good
podcast and I gotta tell you do like it
is a night-and-day different idea I just
had no idea how much the food affected
my mood and and other things that I was
experiencing but I feel great now
and all they did was you a little
breakfast this morning yeah it's funny I
was with dr. Greene yesterday we've
talked about him Alana on the past
podcast before Metro - MD calm he's LA
doctor and helps I was just getting an
IV yesterday before cuz we're recording
this right before we head over to
Australia there's actually coming out
after all Australian tour but we're
recording this a couple days before our
Australian trip and I was getting IV
just make sure I don't get sick at all
because that I live in perpetual fear of
getting sick right before we go out on a
tour and I was looking about I said hey
man thanks for helping out with Ryan and
you know I just cuz that I was
definitely worried when you got that
when you got the test results back but
you've made some significant changes
like instantly cuz you were all I was
telling you were always a guy who was
you you you sort of worn as a badge of
honor that you're an ox man like just
you plow through everything you can get
a little sleep you can eat whatever you
want you can lift small cars above your
head I mean I've seen you over perform
in ways that like you're so durable is
the word I always used to describe you
and and I I envy that durability I don't
have ten percent of your durability I
never felt in Vince
invincible but I certainly have felt
like my Constitution is a bit bit more
than other people but I also am wise
enough to know that that cannot last the
rest of my life yeah and the people who
live like that who live like nothing you
lived real hard especially in your
thirties you mean your 20s you did yeah
or and you've talked a lot about that
during our talks and stuff but during
your 30s not you've lived hard or
anything but but harder than me for sure
but that's just because I got a bed at
eight o'clock at night if I'm if it's
9:30 I'm like why am I out so late
but with you like you you wore that as
this badge of honor I totally get I
think I would have to if I if I was able
to to perform that way but I was talking
to dr. green about it yesterday and he
was like yeah but how many people do you
know like that is to live into their
sixties or seventies or eighties if they
don't make some significant changes in
their life yeah I'm anyone listening
listening to this the reason why I even
got these tests done is because I had a
family member passed away unexpectedly
and they were really really young and it
was something that could have been
solved may have been caught younger than
you younger than me I may have been
caught if they had a blood test yeah and
I thought about the last blood test I
took and it was it was years ago yeah so
I'm like you know what I'm gonna go
ahead the next time I am over at doc
Greene's I'm gonna have him take my
blood and I did and I'm glad I did
because it really it has changed my
perception and has helped me be
proactive to to live a meaningful
healthy life yeah so anyone out there if
you haven't had your blood checked in
the last two years go get it checked
yeah you should do it once a year
probably yeah oh absolutely I mean
that's yeah yeah I know you're going
with the dude if you're if we're getting
our oil change more than our blood check
there's a problem yeah so I'm throwing
the two your two year marker out there
because it's it that is that's way too
long to go start somewhere if it's if
it's been two years if it's been a year
whatever go get your blood checked but
it's it's a very simple thing to do and
if you're listening to me right now and
you're like oh I can't um I don't want
to do that or I'm not gonna do that
Orion's silly or whatever it is that's a
silly attitude to take every severy
single person who's listening to this
should have their blood checked if they
haven't had it checked recently and I
know what the the next thing
the next objection is I can't afford to
and and my response that would be you
can't afford not to
absolutely and because you can't afford
anything if you die it's just it's all
it's all gone or it works you know I was
talking to to to doc green yesterday
about he knew someone who was had a
friend of his their parent was having an
issue with like diabetes whatever an
event she had the like he's like
amputated yeah yeah they amputate your
leg because the the signs were there and
then that changes everything you lose
your mobility if you don't have your
health you don't have anything no and
you know going back to the you can't
afford not to check it for someone out
there who's like oh yeah these guys
don't get it like you know that's that's
a lot of money and and and you know the
you know I I really truly can't afford
to check it if you have a car and you're
changing your oil adopt that attitude
with the blood mm-hmm because I know
that you have that attitude with your
car I cannot afford to not change my oil
because your car's gonna break down so
you have to do this preventative thing
to keep your car going you've got to
take that attitude with your blood and
figure out if you got a whatever it is
whatever you have to do save up a little
bit to get your blood checked that's
fine but please make that a priority
yeah it's got to be a full blood panel
once a year
to let you know where you stand and what
you can improve on yeah and there's so
many things that can be cop I mean just
it's humble it's not just diabetes man
it's so many things yeah that can be
prevented just from a simple test to say
hey look you've got this thing going on
you really have got to address that or
you're gonna problems in a little bit
yeah you you don't want to wait until
the engine falls out of your car I get
it address yeah and that's where I was
heading man yeah yeah anyway all right
what do you think man voicemails let's
do it our first question is from whom
Ryan um I've reached the aisle here we
go
it's from Alex yeah Alex in New York
I've recently been trying to decode in
my life and I'm finding that a lot of my
things are generally cheap such as my
clothing and other daily use items how
do you guys go about buying things with
quality rather than quantity as it's
really a big financial investment from
ghetto to have long-lasting quality
change
I think Ryan some what you think here I
don't like to to think of buying quality
versus quantity always because I think
it's a continuum and I think sometimes
we we often confuse price with quality
we also confuse luxury with quality and
I think sometimes luxury is just a
product of really good advertising yeah
did the the Camry that has this same
it's the same car as I low in Lexus they
just have an emblem that costs $30,000
more right and it might have a few bells
and whistles but right I can't tell you
last time I used to whistle in my car I
was drinking some water I think it was
spit it out of the microphone and so I
think I think we have to think about
quality in a way that means well if we
go back to we go back to that Charles
Eames quo right when we talk about it's
the quality of the connections is the
key to quality per se and so how does
this object connect us with our daily
lives and one of the things that that
Alex here is worried about is his daily
use items and his clothing so daily use
items a lot of those are just disposable
items right so there are some things
that are truly going to be disposable
whether if you're using deodorant or
you're using toothpaste in the tube
you're gonna throw out or whatever and
so you want a higher quality product but
you're going to use on your body or on
yourself it goes back to the health I
mean you're talking about a lot of the
times your blood tests that you're
taking it's about improving the quality
of your life yeah right which in a weird
way actually lends itself to more
quantity of life as well sure no one
wants to live to 200 years old if you're
gonna have a bunch of cancer and tumors
for the last hundred years of your life
you don't want that you want both
ideally but I certainly choose quality
over quantity in those scenarios that
other have a really outstanding 60 or 70
years on earth then a decent 50 and a
terrible 150 years
on earth yeah and so when I look at that
the things that are bring into my life I
look at it as sort of a continuum
because there's a certain amount of
quality that I'll have to forsake I mean
give you an example so I'm wearing this
this cotton t-shirt right now right it's
eventually gonna wear attacked last week
I threw out one of my cotton t-shirts
because that a hole in it now I could
probably sold it for $500 because that's
what the kids are doing these days right
it didn't have enough holes to sell it
yet but when I get a hole my t-shirt I
choose not to wear it but I do
understand this in style now but so I
threw it out right it wasn't donatable I
don't think you could use those rags or
whatever if you wanted to but eventually
they had to get rid of it
now I could wear something that's made
out of you know like I could wear some
sort of armored night suit that is never
going to wear out or get holes in it but
it's not going to have the functionality
that I knew it's actually gonna take
away a certain even though it's gonna
I'm just you know real minimal as you
were and so like I you have to get one
kind kind of quality this sort of
everlasting quality I would actually
have to forsake a different kind of
quality which is like comfort and in
functionality and movability and
breathability and and the ability to to
feel good in what I'm wearing right and
so I think when we're Alex is asking how
do I buy things of quality I think I
think sometimes things can be both they
can be quantity and quality the the the
thing that comes to mind is in a
physical thing for me but it's Seth
Godin he he's the the best blogger alive
or dead not dead but I don't know any
any really good dead bloggers anyway
he's the best blogger ever anyway
he he he puts on a blog post every day
and they're always quality now here's
the thing if you're a brand new blog
you want to start a blog you're probably
not gonna put out very good quality
right away but it's gonna help improve
your quality over time if you did blog
every single day because the more you do
it the better quality the more output
the more quantity eventually leads you
to better quality until the point where
maybe you get close to something like
what Seth Godin is who blogs every day
sometimes twice a day
and it is true quality merged with
quantity
although here's the thing sometimes he
writes three blog posts for everyone he
publishes still still right now that
means he's writing a thousand blog posts
a year so he can publish 370 380 blog
post right now there there are other
ones that I look at the flip side of
that where it's one or the other a blog
that I read occasionally is called wait
but why it's a guy named Tim Urban who
puts that together now these are really
long high quality blog posts so there's
some quantity within the blog post but
he does it very infrequently sometimes
well the blog post once a quarter or
once a month and and that's it but you
can tell he's writing every single day
some of these are 60,000 words long we
novel yeah that is totally a novel and
he has images in it that he draws
himself and like he really dives deep
into the research true quality but he
doesn't put out a blog post every single
day like Seth Godin right now there are
the the click baby things that we see on
websites that are true quantity the
listicles are the the most sort of
rapacious example of of just quantity
the the content factory's content
generation we all know the sites that do
that yeah they just have the top 10 ways
to blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
and it's just putting out content so you
can have banner ads in the side right
and and it's attracting eyeballs but the
people never it's like watching a car
wreck there's no quality there people
will turn their head but then they leave
and they move on and and that's the same
thing with all of this content
generation so quality has to do with
with the the the purpose the meaning
within the creation and not just the the
creating for the sake of more more more
MORE
or yeah now I think it's really easy to
get caught in the weeds man I mean you
really if you're trying to think of
quality versus quantity you can do this
with the most silliest of things yeah
like I'm gonna go buy paperclips I could
sit here and be like okay let me make
sure I'm gonna get the best quality
paperclip that I can get about the money
that I can afford and I guess you know I
guess to look at the other side of this
sometimes the quality really doesn't
matter
yeah you can get neurotic about all
these details it reminds me of this
other this Charles Eames quote that I
have here the details are not the
details they make the product and I
think sometimes we can get so neurotic
and getting everything perfect that we
lose sight of the big picture like what
is the product then if you write this
amazing paper and you need a way to keep
it all together and it's 30 pages long
but then you spend seven weeks figuring
out the right paper clip for that you've
lost sight of the point the meaningful
creation is right there and in fact the
paper or whatever doesn't matter nearly
as much as the thing that you've created
yeah and the paperclip is virtually
irrelevant yes you can you can find a
nice one that is going to work out well
as something that's high-quality but
when you're when your neuro cing over
that and if you forsake the the the
truly important side of things then then
we just get lost in the weeds and we're
never we we never move forward with
something that is true quality because
we're we're trying to affect quality by
by procrastinate yeah yeah I I guess
like I just I really want to just
caution Alex on how much he focuses on
this thing quality because there's also
quality from a perspective of a consumer
and perspective of a creator too right
oh so if we get lost in the quality on
either of those if through either of
those avenues again we're gonna lose the
meaning of the whole thing yeah so for
Alex really ask yourself how important
is the quality of an item that you are
trying to bring into your life if you're
bringing in a paperclip guess what dude
it does not matter the quality of your
paperclip even if it breaks the next day
that's
okay we're not gonna we're not gonna we
wouldn't judge you for it we wouldn't
judge anyone for anything but don't
worry
the minimalist police are not gonna be
you know knocking on your door and
calling you out on buying low-quality
paper clips I have a feeling my friend
Annie who runs a stationary store is
gonna be calling in to our podcast next
week and Leigh but actually it might so
therefore some people that it does
matter when it's a part of the art or
it's a part of the thing that that that
is is I'm saying yes yes absolutely sure
like there is there's an exception to
every rule
yeah yes so unless you are someone who
is a professional using paper clips all
the time I'm not gonna go throw the
caveat that people get it so so don't
get don't get too lost in the quality
now Alex when you do find something that
is of quality and you're like yes like
you know what I need a new car you know
I really want to get that new Model X
Tesla it's a really nice quality car
great go ahead and get that car as long
as you can afford it that's really when
I think about quality that is probably
the thing that I the question I ask
myself the most when it comes to quality
it's not about like how much quality is
an item as much as can I afford that
quality item right and what I mean by
that is like sure can I afford it do I
have the money for it yeah so if that's
that's absolutely the first thing so if
someone has to put something on a credit
card or borrow money from a friend or
whatever it is to buy a quality item
they cannot afford it yeah so that's the
first corner can I afford it monetarily
sure then the next question is is well
can I afford it in my mental space
because I know this is going to take up
a little piece my mental space I know
I'm going to bring this into my home I'm
gonna see this thing on a regular basis
is this truly going to add value is it
truly going to you know serve a purpose
or bring me joy those are the next
questions that I that I start to ask and
then of course there are other costs to
write up keeping the thing storing the
thing painting the paper club cleaning
the paperclip so quality is something I
guess it is important and I think we
should certainly strive to have very
high quality yeah but let's not get lost
in the weeds
when we're looking at quality items
you're not looking for a quality life in
general I'll say that it's the most
important thing but it's not the only
important thing right and so you were
talking about can I afford this thing
and and so the cost often because we
often pay more for high-quality good
it's not always there isn't a direct
one-to-one direct correlation but
there's this term fact the opposite is
true sometimes absolutely yeah sometimes
you'll pay really hot for a high-end
product that I think of some really high
end cars Lamborghinis and stuff that we
see going around Los Angeles and they're
in the shop more than my Toyota Corolla
absolutely man and and so it's a
different type of quality though that
they're trying to get there it's a
certain aesthetic quality but there's
this term financing called dollar cost
averaging and that means it's sort of
the the if you look at like so the
t-shirt that I'm wearing I bought this
t-shirt from eBay but the the let's say
I bought a brand new and let's say it
was 50 dollars for a t-shirt right and I
owned five of them do me do the math
real quick this is a math 550 that's
$250 now what if I bought a hundred
t-shirts there were two dollars and
fifty cents each and they were
considerably less quality you know which
would I rather have right I'd much
rather have the five high quality
t-shirts that feel good that are the
right size the right fit for me or the
opposite could also be true maybe
they're not two dollars maybe there was
five dollar t-shirts and it's about $105
t-shirts I actually ended up spending
more money on those t-shirts because I
had to use a hundred over the same
period where I would use five of these
and you know you can adjust the math
accordingly there to figure out that the
one of the things that is nice about
minimalism needing fewer things affords
me the luxury of having higher quality
items spending more money probably per
item but considerably less on the
overall category of items because I
don't own nearly as many shirts as I
used to own so I the the amount of money
I used to spend on shirts was was
appreciably more than the amount of
money I spend on shirts now but the
average cost of a shirt might have gone
up may probably significantly
gone up a little bit because I was able
to invest in higher quality items and
I'm even using that word invest here
even though I'm encouraging Alex not to
I don't think of my clothes as
investments but in a weird way if I'm
saving money overall in the overall
shirts and I can take that money and
actually literally invest it yeah that's
a people all right Alex I'd love to see
a copy of our book essential it's an
essay collection there's 12 chapters in
there and one of those chapters is on
stuff in particular we talk about some
quality stuff and acquiring quality
items in that chapter so there's 12
chapters about intentional living and
Shaun if you could reach out to him and
get him the audio book if you liked our
podcast you're probably like the
audiobook version of essential or if he
wants the physical book or the e-book
then we can send him one of those
instead all right our next question is
from Cammy in Orange County California
since I have begun this journey on just
um living a more minimalistic lifestyle
I've not only gotten rid of a lot of
things but now when I decided to
purchase something I find myself just
thinking a lot more intentionally about
the product you know I I want to buy
something that will last me a while
that's well made and it doesn't just end
up becoming junk or trash that breaks or
I end up giving away in a short amount
of time
so I would like to know if you guys
personally have any companies that you
feel like are of good quality and are
worth purchasing from whether that's
clothing furniture or I guess just
anything that has stuck out for you guys
since you've become minimalist Ryan what
brands should kami use all of them what
should she buy all the brands recommend
some things silver I you know I do have
brands I like right what are your
must-have items I love I love more
brands that I really like but you love
when we do like a interview with someone
in their lay what are three things a
minimalist must oh that's the whole
point of this whole
well yeah well people like to they like
to make it sexy right yeah well if you
don't like to own stuff what stuff do
you own I mean it's people or
voyeuristic what are the seven things
you couldn't travel without kami I won't
tell you the brands I use because
honestly like I'm not I'm not I'm not
dependent on any brand but I'll tell you
how I choose brands I do a lot of
research so before I really go into
whether it's a pair of jeans or whether
it's a t-shirt or parachute whatever it
is I go way out of my way to find
reviews on it and the reviews have to be
recent because I've made that mistake
before where I find reviews from two or
three years ago and while the product
has changed since yeah they've changed
factories or executives or whatever yeah
and that's kind of Li the inherently
thing wrong with with I think brands in
general is that they the they are a
business who's trying to make money yes
they want to provide a good quality
product but they want to provide a
product that is just quality enough to
keep you invested in the brand hmm
no well it reminds me of this essay by
Colin right I'll try to read a little
bit from it but also reminds me that
this video popped into my head from our
friend Matt Diavel he directed our
documentary minimalism he's working on
our next documentary as well and
occasionally he put some good videos out
about minimalism on his YouTube channel
we'll put a link to this video in the
show notes here but he made this video
about his toaster and about how like
buying the perfect toaster and of course
doing the research and finding the right
thing but then also thinking like once I
acquire this particular item then all of
a sudden I've solved this problem right
and maybe you have if the problem is I
need to toast toast but also toast toast
judge me toast the bread oh that's I've
been doing it wrong this whole time
that's what you don't like no Stephen
doing it wrong man I've been buying
toast and oh my god anyway yeah check
out his video because it he he he used
to be a stand-up comedian and so he
injects like little bits of humor
like how ryan and i try to do on the
podcast but he is actually yeah he's a
deaf he's adept at doing it we're just
we're just silly geese and but he
injects like little bits of humour into
like life lessons as well and so it's a
really good video about his toaster and
he has his girlfriend in there they like
trying to figure out what the right
toaster I figure out why he had us
record the Oh was it yeah he was because
we're the minimalist police is that what
it is
no no he's doing some other video of I
actually don't want to be a spoiler
alert yeah just Matt basically request
that Josh trying to do some voiceover
stuff and one of them was this weird
like yellow through the door and act
like we were cops so I thought it was
gonna be some kind of like he was gonna
do some kind of the minimalist police
type thing or yeah I met with in this
past week to go over some stuff while
you're well we won't ruin it ruin it for
the yeah anyway Colin right are our
other friend we have two friends ones
Matt wants Colin and Colin he wrote this
essay about brand loyalty so cami I
actually will talk to you about some of
the brands that I have in my life but I
will issue a caveat first and that is
the brands that work for me may or may
not work for you but but before we even
dive into that let me just read a quick
excerpt from a rather long essay called
loyalty or happiness brand loyalty
demands that you keep buying products
from a specific company no matter what
you like the brand so why wouldn't you
support their efforts think about that
for a moment brand loyalty means that
even if another brand has a superior
product you'll continue to buy the
inferior one in fact it generally means
you won't even acknowledge the other
product superiority or existence in the
first place you'll spend your money
where you've spent it before because
that's where you've spent it in the past
and that's why I am weary about
recommending a brand in fact I'm not
gonna recommend any brands to you I can
talk to you about some of my experiences
with brands that have worked well for me
now but here's the thing I don't
necessarily have brand loyalty to those
things I recognize that they have a
label usually on the inside because I
don't like to wear labels on my clothes
and advertise for other places in fact
if I could remove the emblems from light
I would do that as well just because I
don't like going around just displaying
logos if when I bike when I buy my next
car I am I'm gonna go to I'm gonna go to
a shop and have him remove everything
you can totally do that
yeah yeah absolutely it's a great idea
man hell yeah dude all right well that's
problem solved dude there we go figure
that out yeah you could totally do it oh
and then he should get a painted flat
black anyway no I mean I saw I had this
I bought this Levi's jean jacket you see
me wear occasionally I bought it from
eBay for like seven dollars and I
removed a little red tag from it because
I just don't like having the outworked
there are some things I have that still
have a small logo on it or whatever
because it would look weird if I had a
patch over it but anyway I doesn't mean
I have brand loyalty to a thing I just
know sometimes some brands have created
good quality but they don't always I
used to buy I was company called Banana
Republic I used to really like find
value from their t-shirts right I almost
had loved their t-shirts stop myself
there I used to really find comfort and
and and I found that they were really
good t-shirt
yeah I mean I feel the same the same way
about them I had I was just telling Sean
this a few days ago I was putting my
socks on and I noticed one of the socks
I was putting on him like this is from
when I worked in the corporate days oh
wow and it was a banana republics like
it's the only pair of Banana Republic
socks I've ever owned but they've lasted
like over ten years man it's crazy man
and so back in 2009 I think the last
time I bought a good t-shirt from them
because and something happened in 2010
where it just changed to garbage their
t-shirts were weirdly sized they were
too tight in the chest and you know I
got those big packs man so like yeah
look out and no but I noticed they were
like they're fitting weird they have
weird tags in them all of a sudden and
the quality of the the cotton was really
odd and and so it stopped working so the
shirts I wear now are from a company
called save khaki and I've been wearing
those for several years now I try to get
them on ebay when I can but if I can't
if I need new ones I buy them right from
their website and and because I like to
buy things that are either gently used
and quite often that means someone just
bought it and never used
they just cut the tags off and had a
sell are you sure but I mean have you
ever had a bad experience money use
t-shirt dude yeah okay how so I'll buy
something from eBay and it shows up and
it's like the wrong color or something
how many times does that happen like
once okay yeah so really it doesn't yeah
in the grand scheme of things when you
average it out the answer is essentially
I only ask because I know if because the
type of person I was hearing you say
that 10 years ago I'd have been like
you're nuts
yeah I'm not gonna buy a used t-shirt
right I'd buy used jacket use jeans you
shoot but for some reason a t-shirt I
would feel like with just you know
people sweating those things more and
the cool things they clean up things
with t-shirts that yeah sometimes that
they feel like they're like nicely
broken in in a while eh if someone wore
it a few times and wash it if broken in
tees patent pending I think that j.crew
already does that I don't buy their
t-shirts either but um nothing I have
anything against them I've purchased
stuff from them in the past point being
is I don't buy a whole lot of new things
now but when I do I like Ryan go out of
my way to do the amount of research make
sure they have a return policy you tell
me that if I don't like I can return it
right I remember I forget what I was
2014 or something as for boots like
recommendation on boots um because
that's you were the person I go to every
time I need fashion advice um but uh but
yet you set me like I was looking at
these reviews and I'm like why didn't I
just look at reviews that makes so much
more sense to be going to judge and
having him look at reviews can you read
some reviews for me you show the stack
of printed out you know and so the the
clothes that I I the last a really long
time in fact they have a lifetime
guarantee this jacket I'm wearing and
also the pants I'm wearing are from a
company called mission workshop and you
guys are great if you want to hear about
all the clothing stuff that we've talked
about in the past I'm sure it's changed
but we did I'm sure it's altered
slightly
probably not that much though episode 56
was podcast called clothing we it's a
deep dive into clothing practices and
then also last week on the podcast
Andrew Morgan and from the true cost
documentary
I'm saying that now even though we're
actually interviewing or not
interviewing them but we're sitting down
with them tomorrow but this episode's
gonna come out a week after that episode
anyway true cost documentary talks about
some of the inherent issues with with
the clothing industry the fast fashion
industry I got to take a step back if
you go listen to that clothing episode I
think I'm going to talk about barbell
jeans on there yeah do not buy barbell
jeans okay they are not high quality
I have not high quality like basically I
got a pair of jeans wore them out
because you know I have only one pair of
jeans right we're mounting like two
months was not doing anything additional
than what I've done to my other jeans
that have left it lasted me a year and a
half to two years that's we were taught
in the zoo a hundred episodes ago or
something
I mean but the long story short like I
called them told them what happened they
were cool but they you know they were
like sorry we're out of that brand you
know or other that nut brand but that
style out of that size in your style as
soon as it comes back in we'll send it
to you did it I finally sent my new pair
of jeans wrong jeans run-length at that
point and this gave up I did wear those
like I got them hemmed and warm and they
wore out in two months
oh here's something funny so we recorded
that well over a year ago not these
mission workshop pants man they've been
lasting I'm wearing the same the same
mission workshop I was wearing we
recorded that podcast that is awesome
yeah that's what I've switched to now
okay there you go ah yeah that's right
you did because we when we filmed the
the new documentary the the talk for
that if barbell didn't charge me $200
for a pair of late low quality jeans
like I wouldn't go out of my way on this
podcast to say don't buy them but yeah
if they would have been 25 bucks or
something yeah it's so soon don't don't
confuse the the price I love the custody
yeah I love the concept but the quality
is is low yeah it was just a high
quantity of money right so yeah I think
Mission workshop has has been good to me
now here's the thing what if their
quality goes down they decide that and
I'll be I'll be talking about them on
the podcast yeah exactly not not the
positive like happy to talk and by the
way with it no none of these no one we
ever talk about ever pays us a dime or
gives us free stuff to I mean I I paid
full price for the jacket I'm wearing
and full price for the pants I'm wear
there's not feel good to like talk about
stuff in a genuine way though yeah and I
feel obligated to talk about stuff
yeah because as you all know we don't do
any any advertisements but uh I had
someone tweet me a few weeks ago and
they said his name was Joe he said what
mattress couch air purifier and/or space
heater do you use and my response to him
was currently : I have no idea none none
and none respectively and I don't know
what my mattress is I know that I tested
out a bunch I don't know the brand of it
because I found one that worked really
well I needed like I want to sleep on
fluffy concrete basically in fact the
brand that you started with I took and
it's an awesome brand for me I love it I
sleep on anything all the time it's the
best freakin bed I've ever had in my
life
right and you hated it yeah so it
doesn't matter it didn't work for me I
had like some weird chemical sensitivity
to it and my match was way less
expensive than that one because it
worked for me and sadly it doesn't work
that well for Beck's
it works okay for her it's super super
firm it's like having slightly damp
concrete and but it works really well
for my back but I honestly I couldn't
you have a gun to my head and said what
brand is it I would guess because I
didn't want you to shoot me in the head
but I honestly wouldn't know I bought it
from a place called Denver mattress when
we were in in Missoula and then what
couch and air purifier and space heater
none none and none but here's the thing
sometimes that changes over time because
we just bought a new couch I supposed to
have it delivered right after this
podcast and bex and I went out and we we
spent I don't know maybe 10 days testing
out different couch it went everywhere
from Ikea to liked on the low end of
things all the way up to like Design
Within Reach the really high end place
and found a place in the middle we there
was a place called blue dot that was had
some really good couches in fact the the
second couch that that we almost went
with we didn't but it was really good a
place called blue dot we ended up in a
place called BoConcept and let me tell
you what man the the couch it was
supremely comfortable except it was 12
of week delivery time and we're like
okay I can go without a key I've gone
without 12 weeks Valley College before
well now it's been 14 weeks and I tell
you what their customer service was
amazing when they were trying to sell me
a couch but now that they've already
sold me a couch and I'm waiting for it
to be delivered and there's like delays
and they're not responding to emails and
phone calls or taking days to get back
to me so guess what BoConcept I wouldn't
recommend you and I wouldn't go back to
me in a bus but both of these things in
the notes Shawn because I want both of
these companies to know that we are not
recommending them yeah yeah and so maybe
say not recommend it here's the thing
yeah I I found a really found a really
good couch that I think I'm going I hope
that I'm going to enjoy and be able to
share that with other people and we have
people over but man the app the the
after the the experience after the
purchase the post sale service it has
not been great mission workshop has been
phenomenal
I remember once they they accidentally
sent me two pairs of pants and so I'm
like you accidentally sent me two I just
emailed the guy who is in their support
department he's like I'm so sorry let me
send you this return label and let me
give you a credit for your next thing if
you ever want to buy anything from us
again and lay they sent me two items and
they're apologizing for it well because
really you could have taken one of the
items and then just returned it and got
free pants I'm right I could have but
what would that I think that shows the
quality of that company they saw that
you could have done that they were like
oh wow like we have a really good
customer we want to show them yeah that
we appreciate them being a great
customer yeah and they have no idea who
I am
we were huge pocket where your couch
your couch company could care less about
showing you that you're a good customer
yeah and what was frustrating is that
they had really high-end stuff and we
paid a good amount it's sort of middle
of the road somewhere between IKEA and
Design Within Reach
and and we ended up paying a nice price
because I what I'm finding now is when
we're talking about quality I want to
bring things into my home and it's my
life that are you might call pieces
they're there whether they're there
aesthetically pleasing so I look at
furniture
often as art but a piece that's gonna
last a long time as long as I need it
right sure just because it lasts 30
years doesn't mean I have to hold on to
it for 30 years but I would like a couch
to the last 30 years it has a potential
and if I decide to let go then hey it
has some resale value and I know that I
can let go of it and part of that just
meant being patient and so I think I
think when we're talking to kami about
any of this stuff is have some patience
going into any of these purchases and
realizing yeah for me it's not a big big
deal waiting 14 weeks for a couch except
when you set the expectation hey it's
going to be twelve weeks and oh by the
way we'll contact you because quite
often sometimes it shows up sooner than
that and all of a sudden I'm 14 weeks
out hoping that the stuff ends up
showing up yeah and it's funny because
those weren't even your expectations
they were the expectations that they set
for you yeah and they're not even
meeting those it's yeah we bash them
enough I think
yeah I'm not matching my own here's the
thing I think they produce really high
quality goods it's the the quality of
the service just hasn't been there and I
expect if I'm doing business with a
company I expect a real customer service
you know it's funny though in LA
specifically there are companies though
who like they pride themselves on
treating their customers like crap
like like restaurants that you go to
like we went to this burger place me and
Jess Williams I'll just drop her off at
the airport when she was heading home
after the special and she can't eat
cheese like she's legit allergic to
dairy like she can't have it yeah so
she's ordering a hamburger she's like
can you please not only can you hold the
cheese on it and they're like oh no we
don't do that we don't we don't change
the items on our menu and that's fine
dude like I totally understand for any
chef out there who doesn't want their
there they're the recipe touched I get
it man Josh and I have a recipe I don't
anybody freaking touch our recipe either
yeah but at the end of the day for for a
restaurant to not be able to not put a
piece of cheese on there that seems a
little freaking insane to me but you the
bartender he she's seen the look on her
face like she was pleased that she was
making us upset and when we were late
I'm like oh like she's actually allergic
to it so there's like there's no way we
can do no dairy on on any of this and
she's like
no I'm so I mean it was so patronizing
yeah and then when we were like getting
up like okay well you know thanks for
your time what we're going to go
somewhere else like the smile on her
face like the satisfaction of sticking
it to us man it just blows my mind you
yeah the cool thing now is you can stand
there right in front of them and leave a
yelp review oh yeah I did and here's the
thing I go way out of my way I leave
mostly five-star yelp reviews and Google
reviews wherever I go in fact it's it's
been ever since I asked for this a
couple years ago is my new year's
resolution to leave more reviews to
review more because we asked people to
review the podcast back there I mean we
don't go out of her way to ask you on
every episode please give us five stars
kind of say if you want to leave us one
star leave us one star it's totally up
to you hop on Apple podcast you hate our
podcast if you feel like we're pieces of
crap yeah yeah if you feel like it's
great and you get immense value from it
that's one way you can help us you know
get the word out there is leave leave a
five star review but I'll go out of my
way and think we'll the place I
BoConcept there based on what the
furniture is I might end up giving them
four stars right sure but then I'll
leave a note about the customer service
and I also know that great piece of
furniture when you get it yeah yeah and
the customer service during the sale was
really solid after the sale it was
really lacking yeah that there was a
breakdown in communication and and so a
few other places really quick for kami
you gotta be really careful with these
but we're gonna put links to both of
these in the show notes buy it for life
is a reddit sub group subreddit I guess
they call it where a bunch of people
talk about different brands where you
buy it once and the middle kind of
million years we would be recommending
reddit well I'm not gonna look at our
ready people
it's just people threatening my life I
know why do people hate us so much I
haven't looked at all at you know
minimalism or whatever and probably five
years ever since maybe longer than that
ever mat tried to like he put a video up
there and tried to get like he's like
hey I'm working on this video I really
want to get some honest feedback and it
was just like you know troll seagull
after seagull but he was like but I love
how that approach that he was like guys
I understand that you're all like in
your little you know mouth-breathing
corners right now
but if you could give me some genuine
feedback that would be great and then
you can resort to you know just tearing
me to shreds yeah so a seagull is
someone who just flies over swoops down
shits on your work and flies away
without adding any value whatsoever but
this buy it for life subreddit has like
400,000 members and it's a lot of people
who talk they share used items they
share links to other items that last a
really long time so buy it for life is
what the name implies there's also a
website called buy this once calm I will
just issue a warning here
be careful about either one of these
because they can also just like the
marketing we talked about with Matt's
toaster then they can encourage you to
buy stuff you don't need just because
something's gonna last for a lifetime
doesn't mean you need it for a lifetime
or need it at all I got an idea if you
need an item mm-hmm write it down on a
list and then go to one of these
websites and look for it yeah do not
preemptively go to these websites that's
a great that's a great point and then
when you go to the website you do not
buy anything that isn't on that list yet
from me my rule is if it's over $100 I
wait 30 days yeah you gotta wait a
little bit man yeah and so I know that's
a bit a bit much for many of you but I
don't want to give that item too much
weight in my life and quite often when I
realized that I didn't need that at all
and so sometimes the best quality is not
owning it at all because then I don't
have to take care of it I don't have to
own it I don't have to think about how
to spend the money on it sometimes
quality means having fewer things so we
can enjoy the things that we do have
kami I'd love to send you a copy of our
book everything that remains there's a
there's a whole chapter in there about
my experience at IKEA you probably
actually saw in the documentary I was
out in the Salt Flats reading from that
chapter and it's not a criticism of IKEA
actually it's like me just trying to buy
everything that's gonna make my life
complete again after it's falling apart
and of course those things aren't gonna
make our life complete so I want to send
you copy that book Sean if you reach out
to her give her the audio book or the
book book or the e-book whatever she
wants we'd really appreciate that all
right where we at Ryan Oh we'd love to
hear what you all have to say so if you
have a comment or a tip about quality
including advice for any of our callers
today then leave us a voicemail for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
you can also send a voicemail right from
your phone to podcast at the minimalists
comm it's my favorite part of the show
we are our favorite comments and tips at
the end of each episode Ryan what time
is it it's time for our lightning round
where we answer questions from social
media indeed we do we are on social
media we're on Twitter and Facebook and
Instagram at the minimalist as our
handle there during this lightning round
this is where Ryan and I both do our
best to answer each question with just a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our quotes in one place
minimal Maxim's calm our first question
is from Juan what's the best approach to
fight that programmed obsolescence that
is engineered by big companies what was
once quality and flagship is now trash
it may can be true sometimes here's my
short answer Ryan most items are
obsolete before we buy them name--in so
so the thing we were just talking about
like putting it on a list and saying can
I wait 30 days do I actually need this
and because maybe 30 days from now I'm
not gonna need in my life at all is this
something I'm going to need now that
doesn't mean you deprive yourself from
something long-term we've talked about
when I got rid of my phone or my laptop
for a period of time accidentally and
and sometimes deprivation helps us
realize that there are things that truly
add value to our lives but I also think
that this obsolescence isn't as big of a
problem as we pretend it is and we like
to think of like these corporations are
the big bad guys not a lot of the
corporations actually add value to our
lives I'm not anti corporation I don't
think corporations are currently bad or
evil I think they can be inherently
problematic because they put the
almighty dollar first mm-hmm and I like
to put people and passion and meaningful
creations first and of course sometimes
that aligns with making profits as well
but I don't think there's this big
conspiracy to plan obsolescence into
everything that we buy there might be
some outliers where some company is
truly planning to make this thing that
is going to be obsolete but they know
it's going to be in
absolutely anyway that's the nature of
technology yeah I mean I can imagine if
I had a company and I'm trying to invent
like I don't know another cell phone for
example like it's gonna get perfect to a
certain point there's gonna be a certain
point where I've got to accept the
technology I have and then call it good
and then finish inventing that thing as
soon as I call it good there's gonna be
new inventions made after that there's
no doubt about it in fact when we went
to that tour at Northrop Gruman yeah am
I saying right yeah they're a big
defense contracting defense contractor
they took us and they showed us the
Robert Webb satellite and it was it's
the satellite that is going to be shot
and it's gonna be shot out a million
miles from the earth if ladies and
gentlemen listening at home if you have
not heard of the Robert Webb satellite
look it up we in our lifetime we will
know 100% sure as long as this satellite
works and everything goes perfect and
the launch goes well which it's
happening this year we will know for a
fact if there's life on other planets or
not it sees that deep into space it will
see the Big Bang it will see remnants of
the Big Bang Theory theory to further
prove this this theory that that has
been you know going around forever
anyway it's an amazing piece of
equipment it's an amazing piece of
technology and what she was telling me
as she was showing us this technology
she was like you know there's some
really cool technology now that they can
I think it's called nano like nano
carbon fiber something along those lines
and she said you know you can take these
nano carbon fibers you can coat it on
anything and they literally going to use
this technology to send a satellite to
the Sun to get pictures in to put it
into a solar flare which is hotter than
what the center of the Sun is and these
nano fibers will protect it it's
unbelievable
she was like that technology came out
one year after we we locked down the
technology on the satellite so they've
got this satellite that is so stinkin
fragile mm-hmm and if and if one little
thing goes wrong then it's gonna be you
know there's like there are billions of
dollars in in you know hours and hours
thousands tens of thousands of hours
invested in this thing that are there's
a lot on the line and what she had said
is she was like you know I I don't beat
myself up over things like that yeah
what's I I think I just I don't I don't
know why sometimes I have dreams about
going back to
blackberry curve phone and you know I
have an iPhone now I haven't had a
blackberry in a while but I've still
what is six years later missed the
keyboard on the blackberry yeah
first drafts of quite a few of our blog
posts from back in the days and then
also my novel a lot of that was written
on a blackberry curve and it's like it's
like having a dream about an old
ex-girlfriend like it's like yeah I
remember the good things in the dream
because it's not a nightmare but I also
realized that you know you're not right
for me anymore and maybe it's you know
that yeah if I brought the the
blackberry curve back into my life it
probably would not be as good as I as I
once remembered it's it's also true it's
it's obsolete with respect to the the
current technology so so Juan don't
worry that much about planned
obsolescence man if you're gonna embrace
technology and not be a hermit you're
gonna have to understand the technology
evolves and that evolution is a good
thing all right here's my short answer
and now that we've got a longer
characters more characters on Twitter I
can make my answers a little bit longer
nice there's always going to be a better
version around the corner and around
that corner and around that corner
stop worrying about the better version
of a material possession and focus on
being a better version of yourself one
doesn't need to buy anything to do that
isn't that isn't that fascinating like
we think that like the toaster like the
toasters gonna make me complete now or
or whatever the item is and and we often
talk about the material possession
should augment or amplify or magnify our
experience of life it's the Charles
Eames quote once again right it's all
about connecting everything and quite
often the material possessions actually
get in the way of of those connections
because and it doesn't have to be just
material possessions it could be
anything that is truly material there's
that Macklemore line with ABS like these
who has time for friends or whatever and
and it's because we're so focused on
this we actually lose the connections
that that truly matter all right our
next question is from
what's your definition of quality well
when he asked this question I first
thought about play-doh I think was quite
quotes from Plato I was thinking that
you like got into Ella's play-doh like
what is the quality of this play-doh and
she ate all of it right OH Plato yeah
yeah okay we had a babysitter over
though then we were going to that we're
going to Paul Johnson Kenya city's
concert and babysitter walked in she's
like where's all her toys and I'm like
they're both over there and I mean she's
got books and other stuff but we mix up
her own game man she plays like any
limitations breed creativity her
favorite toy right now is this stupid
box we we like got this SodaStream new
box patent pending Box TM spaceship so I
just like put her in this box like like
close the top I'm like where's Ella and
or like we'll pick her up and Ryan's
like pointing out quality so we're in
our new studio thank you so much no why
just no notice thank you so much to all
of our patreon supporters where we just
got this new studio lighting in here so
eventually once you have enough
supporters we can do a video version of
the podcast but speaking of quality we
hadn't have this metal fabricated for
this light and then you had to have an
electrician rewire the whole thing to
make it work it's beautiful though and
the lighting when we turn it on I mean
it makes me 73 percent more handsome
really I didn't even realize you get
more hands I was thinking we should turn
these oh yeah we should do that the
podcast with this light from now on it's
pretty bright oh is it yeah yeah might
it might induce a headache if I don't
need it on yeah but it's it is gorgeous
and really high-quality and so we did
spend a little more money getting a
fabric head anyway I've gone way off the
reservation I'm from no no no I
appreciate that thank you to our patreon
supporters for supplying the light
and all the new equipment in here the
sound panels we're doing a video tour
for you all really soon once we once we
get the the final furniture and
equipment in here which will be probably
in April so really soon really soon
anyway a Plato
he says quality is the knife edge of
experience found only in the present
known or at least potentially accessible
to all of us so think about that for a
second quality is known or accessible to
all of us I like this part it's the
knife edge of experience because it is
always now but now it's no longer that
now it's this now and so it's always
this knife edge but if you need a more
cutting edge before it was cool man
if you need a more practical and less
sort of platonic view on quality my
short answer is this raising ones
standards increases the quality of one's
life reach yeah and so I think if
something is high quality then the it or
its high quality when it exceeds our
standards so if we have higher standards
than the quality of our life and the
things that we bring into our life the
quality of our experiences will continue
to improve so raising ones standards
increases the quality of one's life
totally agree when I first read this
question I like looked up the definition
of quality I'm like yep that's pretty
much my definition it is it is one thing
compared to other things that are like
it and it turns out to be the best thing
of a group of things wasn't that the
hold on hold that thought for a second
so my version of quality is gonna be
different from your version of quality
right I mean I Ella has the worst taste
in the world she likes everything to be
purple and lei who's up to her a whole
house would be purple and it's not that
she actually has bad taste it's a that's
more of a criticism of my own taste
Jason yeah yeah a judgment is but a mere
reflecting hit security of the rehab
solutely exactly and so so I look at our
house and I let her have her own little
bits of purple flare in her in her room
but I like a relatively monochrome house
and we get back this summer hopefully
we'll do some apartment tours of our
houses hopefully by then I'll have a Cal
maybe believing I'll be out of my
tournament termite-infested minutes I
think both of us can agree there's no
quality in a termite infested apartment
no definitely but my quality is gonna my
version of quality's gonna be different
from your version it's gonna be there
from other people's versions of quality
so quality is perspectival there's
another there's another pithy quote for
you shot that yeah it's absolutely
alright my short answer is this quality
increases with effort this is - to me
it's 100% true I can look at whether
it's a creation a work of art a product
a an infomercial an advertisement itself
I can tell how much time someone's spent
on it by the quality of that product
right so by default now we got to be
careful - right yeah because I was gonna
say by default the more time you spend
the greater quality it's gonna be that's
always that's not always true either
exactly because you're gonna get to a
point where there might be you no matter
how much more time you spend on it that
thing is it's not gonna be any better
than what you the time you've already
put into it so there's a bell curve
there is a bell curve absolutely yes so
interestingly it's like quality
increases with quantity of effort until
a point that's not as pithy though and
so yeah I like your answer better but I
think that's true there is a bell curve
where eventually you're spinning your
wheels and that that comes down to that
whole thing we talked about perfection
like when we're trying to make this
thing perfect it's never gonna be
perfect and thus you might actually
decrease the quality if you continue to
put in but if you put an unnecessary off
no whoa so quality increases with
necessary effort boom there we go he
decided that in real time in real time
man that's awesome all right no that's
great yeah Shawn use that one um but
what I was gonna say though is like I
feel like every for every piece of
advice we give I have to I have to throw
the caveat on there like most of the
time I think that's implicit in
everything we're saying like there are
always exceptions that are going to
destroy the rule anyway I got one more
question here Lauren says I'm trying to
pay down debt but I also believe in
eating organic and fresh food should I
continue to invest in good quality food
or should I temporarily deprive myself
of that
to pay back debt more quickly I think my
answer to this one is going to surprise
you but if you want that you're gonna
have to tune in to our weekly private
podcast we call it the PostScript
episode sort of little PS to this
episode so each week Ryan and I we do a
postscript episode is a short little
nugget we answer a question or two about
the topic so this week we're gonna
answer Lauren's question and every week
you get a postscript episode it's called
the minimalists private podcast now you
don't have to get on the Internet
log into some website and then every
single time you listen to a podcast I
know you want to listen to this podcast
on your phone while you're driving or
whatever else you can do that with our
private podcast as well so wherever
you're listening to this if you're
listening to an apple podcast or
overcast or feedly or wherever you can
find this podcast and the minimalist
private podcast I'll show up both in
your feed together all you need is the
private link and it's exclusively for
our patreon supporters so if you want to
support this podcast help us keep it a
hundred percent advertisement free and
get the minimalist private podcast every
week then just head on over to the
minimalists com click donate at the top
you can find several ways to support us
on PayPal and venmo but also if you
support us via patreon you get access to
all the bonus stuff so the monthly or
the I'm sorry the weekly private podcast
also the the monthly live streams we
call that ask the minimalists anything
where we host say a video live stream
each month for our patreon supporters
you also get the recordings to our
unpublished live events so we just
published Philadelphia and Detroit and
Tampa and Washington DC and we've got
some others coming soon as well and then
also a studio tour the space were in now
since you all helped us pay for this
space and once we get all the the
equipment in here you'll get add that
you get first access of a video studio
tour thank you so much for being a
patreon supporter if you're helping us
out it means a lot none of the money
goes to me or Ryan it allows us to pay
podcast producer but then also have all
the equipment in the studio space we
need to continue to create meaningful
creations for you thanks so much guys
yeah absolutely so this podcast is free
it's advertisement free but if you want
to support us that is the best way to do
it the minimalists comm and click on
donate over there at the top alright
let's move on to our added value portion
of the show so where we each talk about
something that has
value to our lives recently Ryan what's
added value to your life recently
dude I I didn't realize I could talk
about the wallet that Malcolm Fon ta
gave us uh-huh
because it was a passion project of his
but when we showed up to first talk
about the design of the packed bag
before we even had like a one product of
it okay so to put it in perspective
Malcolm Fon ta is he's guy who made a
bag that ended up in our documentary
sort of accidentally and it was it
plagued to my life for a year because
thousands of emails where do I get that
back he probably had thousands but
probably over a thousand and people were
how do I get your bag I'm like okay you
watched our documentary and the thing
you got out of it is it's like after our
events like people come say what what
brand are your pants say your name all
the time like right now I'm just [ __ ]
its mission workshop right there great I
really do get a lot of value from but I
got pissed at first with this bag
because I'm like but then I realized
like oh this bag was the the one thing
that added immense value to my life more
than it because we travel so much and so
we worked with Malcolm what last year to
try to bring the bag back out the the
kickstart I'm sorry the IndieGoGo
campaign is already over so it's we're
not trying to sell you the bag or
anything but just give you some contacts
on who he is he creates these sort of
amazing designs he's an amazing designer
so we showed up to talk about this the
about this project he gave us this
little wallet called the mojito wallet
and it is the wallet I have been
carrying ever since and it is Leigh it's
super slim I know that it's it and this
is a great example of perspective it's
almost wall it's a minimalist wallet I
love it
Josh wooden carry it I tried it though
yeah absolutely
um but but yeah long story short Malcolm
has said that he's got well actually I'm
not getting to put a number on it
because I'm not I'm not trying to sell
this wallet I'm just saying that if you
are looking for a really nice minimalist
wallet this is one I love it I carry it
making them and he's not making him
anymore
yes no there are all stuff there is a
small stock of them again I'm not trying
to create a sense of urgency here you
don't need to buy it by the way yeah
absolutely not absolutely not but if you
are in the market for it
I would totally recommend I think it's
like 35 bucks and all the the details
will be in the notes of this episode on
how to get it I got a couple of free
things here I'm just going to mention
one thing it's it's one of those mergers
of quality and quantity you know the the
hip-hop band the roots the the lead
singer is he's not a singer the the lead
of every dance yeah they're actually a
band which is weird weird thing to say
in hip-hop but you know the roots oh
they're on Jimmy Fallon tonight now
black thought is the the head of the
band and he did this ten minute
freestyle which is not actually a
freestyle anymore they write these out
obviously this 10-minute long
dissertation one take on hot 97 and it
is so good I mean it is an exercise it
is a holiday where I watch a man it is
unbelievable it is truly unbelievable
let's put a link to that video in the
show notes Shawn he I mean talk about
writing it's a culmination of a lifetime
of writing it's almost like he's
possessed on you know what I'm saying in
a good way he's in a true flow stand
he's flowing like yeah but he's in a
flow state where it is doing that in a
hundred takes is impossible for 99% of
the population him doing this in one
take it is just it's breathtaking it's
mind-boggling in any other metaphor I
want to throw out there one other note
we're doing added value we have a buddy
of ours I've been on his podcast once
and he remember the art of charm
Jordan Harbinger yeah he he reached out
to me and said hey can you let your
audience know that I'm no longer doing
the art of charm and I'd love to get him
on here on the show sometime to talk
about walking away because I think it
was uh IIIi think it was not a friendly
departure on his part even though he was
a part owner of the company and so he
started his own podcast called the
Jordan Harbinger show and it's the same
sort of format he is a he's an amazing
interviewer he I mean he just has these
interviewing chops and I think it's
because he's been doing it for 11 years
yeah I think over a thousand episodes or
900 episodes and he's interviewed so
many people he's gotten so good at
asking good questions high quality
questions and what happens when you
high-quality questions you start getting
better answers and you figure out how to
extract good answers out of people and
then make things interesting and
entertaining and educational and he
walked away from the art of charm
because he was like this no longer sort
of fits the person I want to be it was a
high quality podcast but it's no longer
right for me and so walking away from
that was high quality and starting his
own thing life literally from scratch
when starting his own social media
brands from scratch so he's on Twitter
and an Instagram like starting zero
again and so I'd love to just talk to
him about starting from zero but I told
him yeah I'd be happy to mention the I
get I mean I listen to his podcast right
and I listen when he switched over I I
deleted the art of charm and went right
for the for the Jordan Harbinger show
because he is really good interviewing
people I find value in that so I think
maybe some other folks will as well yeah
I'm gonna recommend one more thing
actually uh I just had I stayed a night
with a gal named Vicki Robin she wrote
your money your life she co-wrote it she
there's a there's a relaunch it's
already out it's I think it's officially
relaunched on April 4th but essentially
your money your life is it's it's like I
feel like if the minimalists were to
write a book on finances that like this
would be this would be it because it's
not it's not a Dave Ramsey approach okay
it is a it's much different it's cuz
it's about the concepts of how we look
at money it's not about here's a plan on
how to get out of money as much as she
helps you realize what we do with every
single cent and it totally I promise if
if someone is looking for a way to help
change your perspective on money this
book will absolutely help you do that
but she's updated it so it was written
back in the 70s it actually came out her
and the intentional simplicity movement
were very much in alignment yeah and it
was so cool like talking with her and
like hanging out with her at her place
but uh but yeah she she updated it April
fourth is one of the Fisher comes out
like I said you can go get it right now
but it's updated to represent late for
21st century rings right it's a modern
take on on finances I think both
approaches are helpful the absolutely
the Dave approach the Dave Ramsey
descriptive yeah yeah yeah how to and
then also like let's have a better
understanding of why we grant we looking
at Dave is a hell - and I think your
money your life is more of a why - okay
cool let's move on to right here right
now real quick let's talk about what's
going on in the lives of the minimalist
we're starting a video podcast really
soon if you want to subscribe to that
you can head on over to youtube.com
slash the minimalists my partner Rebecca
she has a website called minimal
wellness.com
and like once a quarter maybe even a
little bit less than that one about once
a quarter she does something called a 23
day wellness reset and she's doing one
of those in May these always sell out
because there's only 30 virtual seats is
the online program but she coaches these
people directly and then also it has a
daily video and then a weekly a weekly
livestream as well you can find all the
details about that over her web site
minimal wellness comm she's also got a
virtual version of that if you don't
need the one-on-one coaching but you
still want to go through a
less-expensive program she has a virtual
where you still get a video every day
and she sort of helps you do this 23 day
reset reset your life and in 23 days
it's not gonna change your life but it's
gonna help you pivot a little bit in the
direction that you want to go and truly
reset and I know if he's gotten amazing
feedback on that and I'm really proud of
her for what she's doing over there also
if you want all the show notes that we
talked about we're always telling Sean
to put stuff in the show notes
we'll send right to your email box just
go to the minimalists com enter your
email address there at the top any time
we write a new essay so any new writings
but also any new podcast that comes out
that'll show up right in your inbox will
never send you any advertisements or
spam or any of that stuff because that
is disgusting Ryan you got anything else
for us yeah man hold on yeah here there
I got some voice more comments and tips
from listeners hello my name is Aubrey
I'm the librarian in North Dakota and
this is a listeners response to a
podcast topic specifically episode 123
on hobbies someone had asked about
communal craft spaces to share resources
and supplies rather than collecting all
of them yourself many libraries now have
maker spaces for just this purpose so I
recommend that your readers interested
in trying out new technology or creating
something either low
hi-tec to look into their local public
or academic libraries and ask them about
makerspaces that they may have
so in general libraries are an excellent
resource for all but can be a particular
used to those living in minimalist
lifestyle between put ebooks audio books
DVDs books CDs sometimes even sporting
equipment and cake pans and now these
maker spaces there's something for
everyone and it's all for free hello my
name is Elizabeth we're too short I'm
calling from Stamford Connecticut I
would like to leave a comment regarding
the clothes episode I am using an online
clothing service where I rent a certain
number of items for a monthly fee the
company styles the shipment based on
size and climate which is great for
people who are losing weight or pregnant
and you have the final say in what you
receive in that shipment you can wear
the shipment is muster the clothes as
much as you like and you can return the
I the items as a group the company
launders them so it's one less thing to
worry about so for me doing that the
advantages are that I still get to wear
some new trends without the commitment
to buying clothes another advantage is
that I am NOT visiting a store so I am
not tempted tempted by impulse buys I
also find it easier to get rid of some
of the items that I'm holding onto from
my own closet just because I still have
the novelty of being able to get new
items every few weeks some of the
disadvantages is that somebody might do
the service and then they may choose to
keep the clothes that instead of renting
them they continue to to buy them which
could be a problem and in some ways this
is somewhere in the middle of consuming
fast fashion and having fewer quality
pieces owning fewer quality pieces
my name is Vicki Dirksen I live in
Fountain Hills Arizona I have been a
minimal instance before I even knew
there was such a thing as minimalism but
one area that has really suffered in my
minimalism has been my wardrobe and
despise clothes shopping I hate looking
to racks to find something that suits my
style
I hate piecing together outfits I hate
trying on clothes in the store and I
often go far too long between shopping
sessions because I hate the entire
process for whole experience so my small
wardrobe cut first but on your episode
about clothing I think it was Ryan who
mentioned stitch fix so I decided to
give them a try I've received two
shipments already and I absolutely love
it I filled out a style profile online
created a Pinterest board and the
stylist nailed it and has me all set up
for our early Arizona summers I now have
a wardrobe that looks intentional makes
me feel good about myself and I didn't
hate making it happen all right Joe
that's it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalist give us a
call for zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine you can also send a
voice memo right from your phone to
podcast at the minimalists comm and if
you leave here with just one message we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time